we talked about whiskey for a second
sure make up some here brought this
special for you what do you know about
that yeah tell me your thoughts about
whiskey Lagavulin I noticed on the show
you got to visit the distillery I did
somebody gave me Lagavulin a friend of
mine when I was in my 20s and it was the
first really good scotch single-malt
that I had ever tried and I've never
been able to find one that has surpassed
it and my taste coincidentally my boss
on Parks and Recreation Mike sure had
the same experience it was his favorite
scotch and so right away we found that
coincidence tantalizing you know we
began working lager oval and more and
more into the sort of pastiche of Ron
Swanson's characteristics and so then we
were sort of going to London with an
ulterior motive of shooting Chris Pratt
who's there working on a film so we went
to London they said well if we're gonna
go that far we might as well take Rome
to Lagavulin good if you go back and
look at a lot of that stuff you might
catch a tear rolling down my cheek yes
yes I did
great fun cheers Cheers how's that to
you
Mother's Milk
in your book we talked about you had
some time break dancing that's right I
really enjoyed the breakdance period
which in my life was like only about two
or three years it really came and went
it really took off when I was in eighth
grade that's the first school dance that
I remember people busting out moves and
it was funny because it was sort of a
coming-out where everyone had been at
home doing in their basements and you
were like Oh Mike North you can pop in
lot you are not bad bro let's start a
crew check this out yeah but then by
sophomore year high school it faded
really quickly you want it back I want
it back
parachute pants they were the best yeah
I had a pair of silver ones on the
virtues of being handy tell me one more
about that I think the human condition
is one of comfort you know we'll always
take the easier choice modern industry
figured out how to appeal to that side
of our natures and say well sure you
could you could grow a garden that's a
heck of a lot of work and you know what
you're doing it in dirt you know what
that is dirty you're gonna get dirt all
over your hands if you work in the
garden stay in let us grow your
vegetables you know come to our store
etc by now I think we've become so
incredibly soft I have friends that
literally don't know the difference
between a standard screwdriver and a
Phillips head and it's very upsetting to
me we've lost the ability to even fix a
doorknob or almost screw in a light bulb
talk to me a little bit about the
significance of the mustache not just in
terms of Ron Swanson and a character but
what it means for you in terms of being
a man well growing up the mustache was a
great symbol of virility to me I
associated a mustache with well when I
can have a mustache then I can drive the
truck and I can have 12 beers instead of
the mere three they allow me so then
when I became an actor and I was able to
grow a full set of whiskers I was
thrilled that I was able to portray
policemen
Irish thugs what what have you you know
with the different variations and
iterations of facial hair I could I
could pop out everything took a very
sharp turn though when Ron Swanson
became a popular character because I
began to be identified with my mustache
how's your steak delicious yeah good
good you talk about food in your book of
it it's not an antiquated sort of notion
but you are a carnivore you embrace that
in this modern age a lot of attention is
paid to matters of health and I think
being a carnivore especially one that
consumes red meat has taken on a bit of
dark side I think that there's nothing
more delicious than red meat I enjoy it
greatly I have an ongoing negotiation
with my doctor about what I can consume
and what I can and so far I'm still on
my feet and as long as I am I intend to
eat the huge juicy steak let me ask you
what might sound like a silly question
but um do the favorite would sure that
sounds silly at all okay that's like
asking a pianist your favorite composer
is American white oak is to me the most
noble of woods
it's the stoutest it's incredibly dense
it's what the hulls of old wooden ships
were built up so if I could only have
one wood in my shop it would be oak Oak
Oh